hi is this shawn
yes hey sean it's uh jason maradone here
how are you doing thank you thank you
how are you yeah good thanks
i'm sorry i just give you a uh phone
call like this um just call your number
of um james parson
oh yeah yeah yeah so i'm i'm jason
maradon i'm from maradona investments so
i've been teaming up with
james parsons for the last six seven
years
so um yeah just working on investing
opportunities with them
and yeah you just uh you passed on your
number and um
told me i'll give you a call oh yes
yeah i'm just uh i'm just wondering if
um
yeah potentially so we've got a few
investment opportunities during these
times
um obviously getting your investments a
lot cheaper than you usually would
and um a great time to get into the
market as um
yeah a bunch of other boys has around
the rugby scene
yes so there's just in terms of
investment are you talking
shares and or housing or so we talk on
we've got a range of portfolio houses
over
overseas stocks and also start-up
companies um which we have um of full
backing and so personally i've been
investing my own money
in the same shares or some companies i'm
investing my um
my clients money in so yeah we've seen
some great success
oh sweet yeah cool yeah so um oh
i've got this training i'll be
i'll be a minute so we've got this
investment opportunity
it's called fiesta videos so it's what
you see as your petite video store you
know the ones you used to have
yeah yeah so um the the offer going at
the moment is a 43k
and you get 40 of the business
oh yeah so what 40 43k yeah 43k and you
get 40 percent of business
and um like uh to be honest i've got the
other 40k uh 40
because uh you know i i don't want to
see this opportunity pass so
you know i'm backing your money the same
way my my money's going
okay cool yeah so uh are you able to
email me through some
stuff about it or yeah so um i've just
got this um figure here so
obviously there's five million people in
new zealand so uh yeah
we predict it you know if every person
rents their dvd
you know at ten dollars one per year
we're looking at a 50 million dollar
you know revenue income for one year
which means
with all the cost per revenue and things
they will
put around 10 to 15 million dollars in
your pocket
well happy days yeah so is this
something you might be interested in
yeah 100 yeah yeah so um yeah because um
you know the dvds and the vhs are all
making comebacks at the moment
yeah as you as you would see around the
community have you
uh yeah yeah and obviously with this
where the big marketer is at is actually
the r18 videos
which is um the one we're mostly
focusing on so it's going to be
our 18 video shop but um yeah there's
tons of money to be made you know if the
five millions kiwis
all the children wives and and our men
all high
are 18 you know videos you know it's big
money to be made for
both of us all right yeah
i'll send you some more information and
maybe catch up for a coffee and we'll
discuss it a bit um
in a bit more detail yeah no it sounds
good to me
awesome yeah thank you sean i'll be in
touch cheers mate thank you
cool bye